"THE FIVE."
♪ ♪
DEMOCRATS NOW FORCED TO ADMIT TO
WHAT MOST AMERICANS SEE PLAIN AS
DAY, PRESIDENT BIDEN IS A TOTAL
DISASTER.
MULTIPLE MEDIA REPORTS HAVE
LIBERALS BASHING THE
COMMANDER-IN-CHIEF AS WEAK AND
INEFFECTIVE.
COMPLAINING THAT JOE IS NOT
MOVING FAST ENOUGH TO RESPOND TO
MULTIPLE CRISES ROCKING HIS
ADMINISTRATION.
ONE LIBERAL LAWMAKER TELLING CNN
THAT THE BIDEN ADMINISTRATION IS
"AIMLESS AND HOPELESS."
ANOTHER SAYING "IT'S ALMOST LIKE
HE IS HIDING.
HE HAS THE BULLY PULPIT AND IS
EITHER HIDING BEHIND IT OR UNDER
IT.
I DON'T KNOW WHERE HE IS."
AND THE DEMOCRATIC STRATEGISTS
RIPPING INTO BIDEN SAYING "IT'S
INFURIATING OUR HOUSES ON FIRE,
AND IT SEEMS LIKE THEY ARE DOING
NOTHING TO PUT THE FIRE OUT.
THEY ARE JUST WATCHING IT WITH
THE REST OF US.
AND THE USUALLY SYMPATHETIC
MEDIA ALSO BASHING JOE BIDEN.
>> THERE IS THIS SENSE THAT
THINGS ARE KIND OF OUT OF
CONTROL AND HE IS NOT IN
COMMAND.
>> WE NEED JOE BIDEN TO BE
PRESENT AND TO BE A LEADER THAT
MEETS THIS MOMENTS, I MEAN, DO
SOMETHING I THINK IS THE POINT
THAT PEOPLE ARE SAYING.
WE ARE NOT GIVING FOLKS ANYTHING
TO BE EXCITED ABOUT, AND WE
DON'T HAVE THAT FIERCE URGENCY
OF NOW.
>> Judge Jeanine: AND YOU
KNOW, THINGS ARE TRULY A
DISASTER WHEN HOLLYWOOD
CELEBRITIES JUMP SHIP.
ACTRESS DEBRA MESSING REPORTEDLY
FED UP ABOUT PRESIDENT BIDEN'S
LACK OF URGENCY AND THE
ADMINISTRATION BEING UNPREPARED
DESPITE WEEKS OF WARNING ON THE
REVERSAL OF ROE VS. WADE.
SHE ALSO REPORTEDLY CLAIMED
CREDIT FOR GETTING JOE BIDEN
ELECTED.
I GUESS WE BETTER DO A CHECK ON
WHETHER OR NOT DEBRA MESSING
ACTUALLY GOT JOE BIDEN ELECTED.
BUT JESSE, I WILL START WITH
YOU.
WHEN THEY SAY WE NEED HIM TO BE
PRESENT AND TO BE THE LEADER, IS
JOE BIDEN CAPABLE OF THAT?
>> Jesse: NO, HE NEVER WAS.
AND BIG TECH AND CHINA WERE
LIKE, WE GOT JOE BIDEN ELECTED.
JUST HIS SCHEDULE THIS WEEK IS A
PERFECT EXAMPLE.
IT'S LARGELY CEREMONIAL, ON
MONDAY HE HAS A BARBECUE FOR
JULY 4TH, ON TUESDAY HE HANG
SOME METALS AROUND SOME HEROES
NECKS.
ON WEDNESDAY HE FLEW TO A SWING
STATE AND GAVE A SPEECH ON WHAT?
THE AMERICAN RESCUE PLAN HE
PASSED LAST YEAR ABOUT COVID.
AND TOMORROW HE IS GOING TO
LANGLEY TO CELEBRATE 31 YEARS IN
THE CIA AND FRIDAY HE JUST FLEW
TO DELAWARE FOR ANOTHER THREE
DAY WEEKEND.
IF YOU ARE GOING TO GIVE A
SPEECH, HOW ABOUT GIVE IT ON
INFLATION OR GAS PRICES, THOSE
ARE THE MOST IMPORTANT ISSUES OF
THE DAY, OR YOUR BASE CARES
ABOUT ABORTION AND GUNS, HE DOES
NOT DO ANY OF THAT AT ALL.
THEY WANT HIM TO PERFORM.
TO THE PRESIDENCY IS A
PERFORMANCE.
IF THE SUPREME COURT COMES DOWN
WITH A MAJOR ABORTION DECISION,
YOU CANNOT GIVE A SPEECH, FLY TO
DELAWARE AND THEN TAKE THE WHOLE
NEXT WEEK AND GO OVER TO EUROPE.
YOU CAN'T DO THAT.
TO THE LEFT WANTS TO SEE HIM
SPITTING MAD, HANDS IN THE AIR
OUT ON THE STREETS, RAISING, AND
HE JUST DOES NOT HAVE IT IN HIM.
THEY WANT HIM TO ATTACK THE
SUPREME COURT, HE DOES NOT DO
THAT.
HE CANNOT ATTACK REPUBLICANS,
THEY ARE NOT IN POWER.
THEY TRIED THE ULTRA MAGA THING,
BUT IT WAS CORNY AND VAGUE AND
THEY PUT IT TO BED.
SO WHAT IS YOUR PLAN OF ACTION
AFTER ROE V. WADE?
THEY DO NOT HAVE ONE EITHER.
PUTTING ABORTION CLINICS IN
NATIONAL PARKS IS NOT A REAL
PLAN, YOU HAVE TO GO TO THE
STATES.
AND THAT'S WHERE THE ACTION IS.
BUT UNDER OBAMA THEY LOST LIKE
EVERY SINGLE STATE IN THE
COUNTRY, SO IT'S GOING TO TAKE A
LONG TIME AND A LOT OF HARD WORK
AND GROUNDWORK TO GET BACK TO
WHERE THEY NEED TO BE.
>> Judge Jeanine: SANDRA, YOU
ARE THE ECONOMIST AT THIS TABLE.
WHAT PEOPLE ARE CONCERNED ABOUT
AS JESSE SAID, INFLATION IN THE
ECONOMY, KARINE JEAN-PIERRE SAID
YESTERDAY IN TALKING ABOUT THE
ECONOMY SHE SAID BUSINESS
INVESTMENTS, DO WE HAVE A SOUND?
OH, GO AHEAD.
>> WE HAVE AVERAGED MORE THAN
4,000 JOBS EVERY MONTH FOR THE
PAST --
OVER THE LAST MONTH, THREE
MONTHS, WE HAVE HELPED HOLD
STEADY AT 3.6 UNEMPLOYMENT
RATES, CONSUMER SPENDING IS
STRONG AND ABOVE PRE-PANDEMIC
TRENDS, BUSINESS INVESTMENT A
STRONG AND HOUSEHOLD AVAILABLE
SHEETS REMAIN STRONG.
>> Judge Jeanine: THE THING
THAT JUMPS OUT IS WHEN SHE SAYS
HOUSEHOLD BALANCE SHEETS REMAIN
STRONG.
>> Sandra: IF THAT WAS THE
CASE HE WOULD NOT HAVE 23% OF
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE HAVE LOST
PART CONFIDENCE IN THE
PRESIDENCY, JUST 10% SAY THAT
THE COUNTRY IS IN THE RIGHT
DIRECTION.
AND WASHINGTON POST ONCE AT
SHIFT CHANGE IN THE PRESIDENCY.
AND WE WANT TO THE PRESIDENT TO
GET LOUD.
WE WANT THE PRESIDENT TO FIGHT,
THEY WENT TO SEE ANGER, ANGST,
URGENCY TO THE POINT ON THE
ECONOMY, IF THERE WAS A MORE
TELLING POINT OF THE PRESIDENCY,
IT'S THAT THE NUMBER ONE CONCERN
OF THE AMERICAN PEOPLE AS
INFLATION AND HIGH GAS PRICES.
WHAT DOES HE DO?
HE GOES ON AND SAYS I KNOW THAT
IS THE PRIORITY OF THE PRIORITY
FOR US AND WE ARE DOING
EVERYTHING WE CAN TO BRING DOWN
THOSE PRICES.
WHAT DOES HE DO?
HE TAPS THE WRONG MOVE, NOT HOW
YOU ADDRESS THE PROBLEM AND HAS
NOT BROUGHT DOWN GAS PRICES AND
THEN WHAT HAPPENS?
REUTERS REPORTING YESTERDAY THAT
THE OIL THAT IS COMING OUT OF
THE EMERGENCY RESERVE IN THIS
COUNTRY IS GOING WHERE?
NOT INTO THE GAS TANKS AT THE
AMERICAN PEOPLE, BUT IS GOING TO
CHINA.
>> Judge Jeanine: IT IS
OUTRAGEOUS.
>> Sandra: IN THE WHITE HOUSE
HAS ASKED ABOUT IT, AND
KARINE JEAN-PIERRE DOES NOT EVEN
KNOW ABOUT IT.
AT LEAST SHE SAYS SHE DOESN'T.
>> AND I BELIEVE SHE DOESN'T.
JESSICA.
WHO I NEED TO PUT A QUESTION TO
YOU.
CAN YOU GET ANY LOWER IN TERMS
OF THE NUMBERS?
OR HAS HE HIT ROCK BOTTOM?
>> Jessica: TECHNICALLY HE CAN
GO LOWER, I DON'T THINK HE WILL,
36 PERCENT IS OUT THERE RIGHT
NOW, I THINK THAT'S PROBABLY
WHERE HE WILL HOVER.
TWO THINGS THAT I WANTED TO
SPEAK ABOUT, ONE, I THINK THAT
THE FRUSTRATION OF HAVING SIX
WEEKS TO BE PREPARED FOR THIS IS
SO IMPORTANT TO UNDERSTANDING
THE IDEA OF LIBERALS RIGHT NOW,
BUT ALSO MODERATE REPUBLICANS
WHO WOULD PREFER THAT WE HAVE
SOME NATIONAL PROTECTIONS.
AND WE SAW THE POLLING FROM
EARLIER THIS WEEK THAT WELL OVER
60 PERCENT WERE IN FAVOR OF A 15
WEEK BAN AND WHEN YOU LOOK AT
SOME STATES THAT HAVE THE
10-YEAR-OLD GIRL FROM OHIO WHO
WAS RAPED BECAUSE SHE WAS SIX
WEEKS AND THREE DAYS PREGNANT,
THEIR PARENTS HAD TO TAKE HER TO
INDIANA TO GET AN ABORTION, YOU
CAN UNDERSTAND WHY PEOPLE ARE
SAYING, WHY DO WE NOT HAVE A
PLAN TO COMBAT THE CHAOS?
>> Judge Jeanine: WHY DIDN'T
THEY?
>> Jessica: I DON'T KNOW, I
DID NOT WORK FOR THE
ADMINISTRATION.
>> Greg: YOU DO.
IT >> Jessica: I DEFINITELY
DON'T.
DON'T START THAT RUMOR.
SIX WEEKS IS A LOT OF TIME TO
PUT IN PLACE PLANS TO LEAN ON
STATE LEGISLATURES AND GOVERNORS
TO MAKE SURE THAT PEOPLE CAN
ORDER YOUR ABORTION PILLS ONLINE
AND CROSS STATE LINES ET CETERA,
THERE IS AN INTERESTING
PHENOMENON GOING WITH THE
POLLING, SO DEMOCRATS ARE
RUNNING WELL AHEAD OF JOE BIDEN.
AT SO WE LOOK AT FISA GATE RIGHT
NOW, THEY'RE UP IN TEN POLLS
THAT HAVE COME OUT IN A POST-ROE
WORLD AND THE DEMOCRATS ARE
LOOKING AT THE CONGRESSIONAL
BALLOTS IN ALL OF THAT, WE SEE
THE SWING AND THE DEMOCRATS
FAVOR, AND IT'S INTERESTING AND
A REFLECTION OF WHAT IS GOING ON
IN THE PUSHBACK BETWEEN WHAT
PEOPLE RIGHTLY FEEL OUR
EXTREMIST REPUBLICAN POLICIES.
IT SO I WONDER HOW MUCH
CAMPAIGNING JOE BIDEN IS GOING
TO END UP DOING FOR THE MIDTERM
IF SOMEBODY LIKE RAPHAEL WHILE
NOG GETS TEN IN GEORGIA, MAYBE
PEOPLE WILL GO WITHOUT THEM.
JOHN FED HER AND IN
>> Judge Jeanine: THAT IS YET
TO BE SEEN, BUT GREG, HOW DO YOU
RESPOND TO THAT?
>> Greg: I DON'T.
>> Jessica: THAT'S NOT FAIR,
YOU MAKE ME RESPOND TO YOU ALL
THE TIME.
IT >> Greg: I HAVE A REALLY
GOOD JOKE BY YOGI BERRA.
I THINK WHAT WE ARE LOOKING AT
IS A LARGE HOLE, LEFT VACANT BY
THAT JANUARY 6 HEARINGS.
YOU SEE WHY THOSE WERE SO
DESPERATELY EMPLOYED AND SO
DESPERATELY NECESSARY FOR THE
DEMOCRATS, RIGHT?
BECAUSE IF YOU WANT TO REMOVE
IT, WHAT YOU HAVE IS A GAPING
LACK OF LEADERSHIP, A GAPING
LACK OF OPTIMISM, COMMON SENSE,
WISDOM.
WE HAVE A GIANT HOLE WHERE
LEADERSHIP SHOULD BE.
THAT IS WHY, SO NOW WHEN YOU
LOOK AT THE JANUARY 6 HEARINGS,
BECAUSE IT IS COMING BACK.
YOU NOW KNOW WHY IT IS THEY ARE,
BECAUSE WHEN YOU TAKE IT AWAY,
THIS IS WHAT YOU GET.
YOU GET THIS GRIM TESTIMONY
ABOUT THE NATURE OF THIS
WHITE HOUSE, SO THE MEDIA HAS
CHOSE TO AMPLIFY THE HEARINGS
THE SAME WAY THAT THEY D
AMPLIFIED THE HUNTER BIDEN
LOCKDOWN STORY BEFORE THE END
ELECTION.
IT'S BEFORE AN ELECTION, IT WAS
BEFORE AN ELECTION THEN, THAT'S
WHY NO ONE SHOULD BELIEVE OR
TRUST ANYTHING COMING FROM THE
ST. PAUL THAT DID THE HUNTER
BIDEN LAPTOP AND ALSO HIS
HEARING, IT'S THE SAME THING.
THAT DOES NOT MEAN THAT THE
REPUBLICANS ARE JUST GOING TO
STAY THROUGH THIS, WHAT BOTHERS
ME IS I DON'T LIKE THE DANCING
ON THE GRAVE PRELIMINARY KIND OF
CELEBRATION.
THERE IS NEVER BEEN A BETTER
TIME FOR THE REPUBLICANS.
OUT OF THE DEMOCRATS IN A WOKE
PARALYSIS, RIGHT?
THE LOUDEST MOST UNHINGED VOICES
CONTROL THEIR PARTY AND HAVE
RELINQUISHED ANY CONCERN FOR
PARENT TO THE REPUBLICANS.
THE REPUBLICAN PARTY IS NOW THE
PARENT PARTY AND WE MENTION THAT
EARLY ON DURING THOSE SCHOOL
BOARD HEARINGS WHEN WE SAID
THERE WAS A GREAT OPPORTUNITY
WHICH IS WHAT HAS HAPPENED, BUT
YOU CAN'T JUST CLUCK ABOUT IT.
YOU HAVE TO BE PERSUASIVE TO THE
VOTERS AND TAKE IT TO THEM AND
PRACTICAL SOLUTIONS ABOUT THE
ECONOMY AND PRACTICAL SOLUTIONS
ESPECIALLY ABOUT CRIME, BECAUSE
WE HAVE NOT SPOKEN ENOUGH ABOUT
THAT, THE CRIME THAT IS GOING ON
ALL OVER.
IT'S NOT ENOUGH TO SAY AHA, WE
HAVE TO HAVE SOME TESTIMONY AND
WHEN I SAY US, I MEAN NORMAL
COMMON SENSE NONWOKE PEOPLE.
AND I INCLUDE DEMOCRATS IN THAT.
I THINK THAT THIS IS THE TIME
FOR MODERATE DEMOCRATS TO COME
BACK AND KIND OF LIKE
REDISCOVERY -- REDISCOVERED THE
JOYS OF COMMON SENSE.
>> Jesse: MODERATE DEMOCRATS,
ARE YOU OU